[Music]
there's a lot of kind of discussion of
what the political beliefs of Silicon
Valley elites and founders are but we
actually have no hard data on what they
actually believe when it comes to
politics and policy
some people say Silicon Valley is really
libertarian other people say Silicon
Valley they're all just like loyal
Democrats Silicon Valley you know they
all just care about these social issues
and they're very far left on social
issues however although there's been a
lot of thinking about for example people
on Wall Street how do they think about
politics what do they want how do they
interface with the political system
there have been much less thinking about
that same question in the context of
Silicon Valley
technology elites are basically liberal
on every dimension you could think of
except regulation and this is actually
really interesting because there's no
other group of people that we surveyed
that have this constellation of
political beliefs and specifically when
it looked you come to economic issues
they are not easily categorized as
libertarians
because they believe in the
redistribution of income for things like
health care and education and poverty
reduction but at the same time they
believe that government should not be
regulating business and some people have
now called this new type of political
animal the liberal terian so they're
trying to find new words and
terminologies and so it's been kind of
interesting to see how people have tried
to introduce new categories to match the
results we've been finding
a lot of Silicon Valley companies right
now are intervening in labor markets
uber is a great example where there's
the question of whether gig workers for
uber should be treated like regular
workers or as contractors you can
imagine labor unions see that as a
classic case where it's important these
workers receive protections all the
protections that would be associated
with traditional employees whereas
technology entrepreneurs look at this
and they say no we shouldn't be
regulating how these companies um treat
workers we should give them freedom in
the marketplace and so that's a classic
example where I think in a lot of states
that issues starting to come to a head
and you could imagine it's the sort of
thing that those who work for tech
companies who are doing more donating to
Democratic campaigns are gonna say
actually we disagree with the labor
unions that are endorsing you we think
you should take this other position on
this issue so those kinds of tensions
within the Democratic Party we think are
going to become increasingly common
a lot of historical research is found
that parties usually change when there's
important groups within those parties
that agree with them on most things but
disagree with them on a few things and
then they shape the party in that
direction so a classic example is at the
afl-cio the CIO portion of it before it
merged was very tolerant of racial
progress and at the time the Democrats
had a lot of virulent racist people as
leaders in that party and they sort of
used labor which they agreed with the
Democratic Party on and shifted the
Democratic Party to being more of a pro
civil rights party and this pattern has
emerged over and over again in American
history
so one prediction our research suggests
is that as technology elites become more
important part of the Democratic Party
in terms of his fundraising apparatus
they are going to double down and
promote traditional democratic interests
when it comes to Social Policy
redistribution foreign policy
immigration but try to move it towards
the right on issues when it comes to
regulation particularly of labor markets
I think a big question right now in
politics is the gap between elites and
masses and for the whole post-world War
II period there's been sort of an
agreement that we would devolve some
power to elites who would then look out
for like everybody's interests but
increasingly we've seen populist revolts
going on in the United States and all
the way across the world where people in
the masses have kind of realized our
wages have stagnated expenses and real
terms have gone up on things like health
insurance and college tuition etc and
our children are going to be living
worse lives with the worst standard of
living than we did and so there's a lot
of discussion about well how is our
democratic institutions gonna survive if
there's not going to be cooperation
between masses and elites so I think a
lot of this research has to continue to
explore this question more I think David
and I are just generally interested in
kind of understanding well who are the
elites and what does that mean and
what's they believe and before we did a
study like this there really was no data
and it's because these are very hard
people to interview and get their
opinions on and I think just future work
needs to be done on this topic so we can
understand the contours and potential
fault lines in politics both in the
United States and abroad the other
transformation you've seen economically
for a lot of Americans is not only have
we - stagnated but people are exposed to
increasing risk and so a lot of the kind
of government-run programs that
technology entrepreneurs can be more
skeptical of they're not just about
transferring resources they're about
some form of social insurance and so I
think as people are exposed to more and
more risk that might be an experience
that technology entrepreneurs haven't
directly experienced as much and so
that's another gap that I'm interested
in in looking at I'm a big believer that
I think social science should be
addressing questions that are important
to the broader world that if the world
says these are the issues that are
important to how human beings are gonna
have to grapple with their democracies
their societies so that's what academics
should be studying and so that's one
reason I was very proud of this study is
that these issues of inequality
automation technology this is
what the world is facing right now and
so I think it's important to address
questions that are relevant
[Music]
you